this video is sponsored by
curiositystream and nebula the modern
world is amazing humans have created
systems that allow them to travel entire
continents in a single day systems that
free them from physical labor allow them
to eat whatever they want to Shelter
From the elements and these Miracles
have come about through two factors the
use of energy and the idea of
individuals and corporations controlling
the means of production in other words
capitalism while undoubtedly effective
these factors have unfortunately damaged
our environment because there's no
short-term Financial cost to doing so
pretty much all human activities result
in the emission of greenhouse gases most
notably carbon dioxide and those gases
are causing the climate to change to
prevent catastrophic change from
occurring then we need to stop emitting
those greenhouse gases but that's a task
that spread across all of society each
of these squares represents one percent
of all greenhouse gas emissions in 2016.
approximately 16 percent of all
emissions came from transport 24 percent
from energy used in industry 17 from
energy used in buildings and about 14
from other uses of fuel using energy
accounts then for almost three quarters
of our emissions the remainder comes
from landfills how we use the land
notably for agriculture which is about
11 of all emissions and from other
industrial emissions in particular
construction let's be super optimistic
and say that we can fully decarbonize
how we generate and use energy almost
three quarters of our emissions gone but
that still leaves over a quarter we can
reduce some of these emissions by
stopping deforestation producing Less
meat and having better waste management
but that still leaves billions of tons
of carbon that are emitted every year
from Agriculture and from construction
and construction uses a lot of cement
made in a plant like the one behind me
and that's a big problem so how you make
cement is you take a mixture of raw
materials a large proportion of that is
calcium carbonate CaCO3 you heat that up
to a very high temperature and a
calcination reaction occurs which is the
CO2 is separated from the calcium
carbonate to leave calcium oxide which
is then used in the cement process that
CO2 is emitted to Atmosphere at the
moment the emission of CO2 is
unavoidable as part of the cement
production process due to the chemicals
that form the cement precursors for that
reason that even if you were to run the
cement production process on renewable
energy for the heat Source you would
still have an emission of CO2 and you
know what makes this even worse the fact
that we're not going to stop building
new buildings anytime soon in fact about
three quarters of all of the
infrastructure that we need by 2050
hasn't been built yet so this is is
cement is really very important for
urbanization for our infrastructure and
it really needs to be something that's
available globally and cheaply this is a
huge problem one of many that needs to
be sold if we're going to avoid
catastrophic climate change my videos
are often very top down and not specific
and they also almost always end with
some variant of this is serious but we
still have time so let's do something
about it in this video then I'm going to
do something a bit different I'm going
to shine a light on one particular
aspect of the climate crisis and on
something that we are doing I'm going to
talk about a company called lilac which
aims to decarbonize the cement industry
we're about an hour and a half southeast
of Brussels where there is a cement
plant and on this cement plant we've
constructed the Lilac One Pilot plant
for the purpose of demonstrating the
Lilac technology and just to be clear
calyx isn't paying for this they haven't
paid me they haven't sponsored the video
but it's invited me to come and have a
look at the plan and judge it for myself
as a further disclaimer let me be clear
that this is not the solution the
company says as much they are just one
of many companies working in the field
of decarbonizing cement if you'd like to
learn more about other people working in
this industry then check out just have a
think's excellent video on the subject
with all that being said though let's
take a look at a case study of a new
technology being used to combat part of
the climate crisis why it's being used
and where we are on a timeline lilac
stands for low missions intensity lime
and cement and this is a new type of
carbon capture technology that has a
heated tube at its heart so it has a
furnace that gives us energy and heat to
this this steel tube and down the center
of that tube we simply drop this cement
meal it's mint meals largely contained
Limestone and Limestone releases almost
half of its weight as CO2 and so this is
an unavoidable part of making cement
this is just a way of ensuring the CO2
the that is released from that limestone
is kept pure and so the real benefit of
this is that unlike other catch
technologies that require energy to
separate a gas from a gas by keeping the
CO2 pure and by closely integrating with
the plant
we don't have much of an energy penalty
and so therefore we should be able to
capture these process emissions at very
low cost this plant has been retrofitted
with a prototype of the Lilac technology
capturing the carbon given off during
the cement production process let's see
how it works so what we have in front of
us here is the Lilac pilot plant itself
this pilot plant process is about five
percent of the cement plants total
throughput so it's not completely
integrated with the cement plant using
this facility we've been able to
demonstrate that the core technology the
core lilac technology works so that up
there which is being worked on at the
moment is the bottom of the reactor tube
the very hot cement meal that's been
calcined and emitted at CO2 has come out
of the reactor tube comes down this
funnel and then it drops down and
through this air slide to be taken away
back to the cement plan
so this is the bottom of our furnace
this is where we heat the reactor tube
up to the Thousand degrees Celsius it
needs to drive the calcination reaction
in lilac one we use natural gas but in
lilac 2 and in future projects we'll use
the sorts of fuels which cement plants
typically use which would be more like
alternative fuels and things like that
so this is the top of our reactor tube
so we're standing above the top of the
Furnace which heats up the reactor tube
the material which is being processed is
dropped into the tube from this point
and the CO2 is extracted from here as
well to be cleaned up and returned to
the process so this is where a lot of
the smarts of the technology is uh
focused lilac one has done its Duty it's
demonstrated that the core technology
works so this won't exist on lilac 2
this is a burner it's there only to
allow us to test the Cyclone stack above
it provides hot gas for the Cyclone
stack which allows us to test the
operation of of that so this is where we
start to get to the more typical cement
equipment what we have here is a
three-stage cyclone stack each stage of
the Cyclone contributes to the
preheating of the cement meal we have to
design this part of the process to sort
of sit on this optimal point where we've
done as much preheat as possible without
calcining the material and every bit of
CO2 that we extract here is a bit of CO2
that we can't separate within our
reactors it's worth stressing by the way
the Lilac technology isn't capable of
fully decarbonizing cement production on
its own because the emissions from
cement production aren't just from the
chemical reaction they're also from the
fuel burned to heat up various
components you're quite right there are
other sources of emissions to create the
heat required to drive off that CO2 we
need energy and traditionally that's
been through the use of coal and coal is
an emitting fossil fuel there are two
main routes to go down one of which is
just switching to lower fossil fuel or
lower emitting fuels a again with our
technology we just need to heat a steel
tube so we can actually be fuel agnostic
so we'll start off on whatever the host
plant is using whether that's
alternative fuel and then have the
option to moving to zero emissions fuels
such as clean electricity or hydrogen or
biomass the other route that we can take
is actually just capturing those fluid
emissions using a very small additional
capture component so we've got a lot of
options when it comes to complete
decarbonization and potentially even
carbon negative CO2 now there are
probably some of you in the audience who
are aghast at me talking about the dirty
subject of carbon capture that's what
lilac is it's an example of carbon
capture technology and you may be aghast
because it's something that I have very
publicly dismissed in the past but in
the past I don't think I did a very good
job of making a very important
distinction carbon capture can refer to
sucking carbon out of the atmosphere
direct air capture or stopping carbon
from entering the atmosphere at the
point it's burned carbon capture and
storage or CCS the reason that I and
many others are opposed to carbon
capture is that historically it has been
used as a justification for continuing
the burning of fossil fuels we can keep
burning the fuel we'll just capture the
CO2 like now or maybe later frankly
doesn't work and delays meaningful
change prolonging our dependence on coal
oil and natural gas and I want to be
clear my stance has not changed on that
carbon capture is not an appropriate
tool in the context of energy production
in this instance however we are talking
about the ccs of unavoidable emissions
the use of carbon capture in the context
of cement production isn't delaying
decarbonization it's pretty much the
only realistic path to decarbonization
because of how cement is made and the
fact that cement production that simply
isn't going to stop but let's say that
we don't want to fund any kind of carbon
capture lest the technology be used
elsewhere And Delay meaningful change so
what are the Alternatives well
alternatives to cement I mean cement is
one of the most used raw materials in
the world I think it's the second most
after water so it's uh it's used just
everywhere wood might be considered an
alternative it's a building material
there are other building products such
as calcine Clays which don't inherently
emit CO2 through their production
process however there are barriers to
the use of those materials that are
nowhere near as well known as Portland
cement the building standards are not
based around those materials so they
can't just be dropped in as Replacements
so for the moment there are no real
drop-in alternatives to cement when
we're building bridges and and our homes
roads and general infrastructure it is a
very low cost very stable very well
understood and safe material we can't
really use materials that that can only
be used by the really rich Society
sections of society this does need to be
material that's used used globally and
widely this Century we have to balance
idealism and realism there are a great
many opportunities in the coming decades
to remake sectors of society of Industry
to be more egalitarian and inclusive and
efficient
but we have to accept the fact that we
don't have long to decarbonize the
world's economy just a few decades while
an ideal solution in construction would
probably involve some new material that
can be made cheaply and in a way that
doesn't emit carbon CCs is a technology
that already exists it doesn't require
new legislation and can act as a short
to medium term solution and be rolled
out in just a matter of years in a way
that the industry can actually get
behind this was the first plant this is
kept got the capacity to capture about
25
000 tons of CO2 per year this is about
five percent of a typical cement plant
throughput the plant that we'll be
building in Germany next year that's
four times the the capacity it's got a
similar footprint but four tubes in it
and that's effectively 20 of an entire
plant's emissions that we'll be
capturing that's about a hundred
thousand tons of CO2 and that forms a
module that we can very simply duplicate
so we'll be able to get to a hundred
percent
very quickly in fact we're already
starting full scale engineering that
will really capture all of the
unavoidable process missions now so in
theory depending on how quickly our
other cement plant hosts can move we
should be able to have something
operational by 2026 perhaps but before
drawing this to a close I just want to
point something out how do we get in
this mess the reason that we're in this
situation is because we live in a world
governed by capitalism and under that
system there is no cost to emitting
greenhouse gases and so no incentive to
not do so climate change is an unpriced
externality yet here we have a company
lilac whose business model is based on
preventing carbon emissions
so what changed it has required the
intervention of governments through
these funding mechanisms in order to get
through the development stage and the
scale up stage which is notoriously
difficult for new technologies it's very
much like the difference between waste
water so that if you've got your sewage
if you're not obliged to treat it just
dumping it in the rivers or sea is costs
you nothing but when it's just a obliged
to treat those emissions then that's
just a cost so policy is extremely
important this co2's ultimate we know it
is something that shouldn't go into the
atmosphere and so it is ultimately
something that we just needs policy
support to get there with Europe we've
got the green deal we've got a missions
trading system and that's going to get
us to zero the cost of emitting carbon
through Europe's emissions trading
scheme is an example is something which
is going to be necessary to roll out the
technology even if we come up with the
perfect solution if it's cheaper just to
omit the CO2 everyone will just do that
so there needs to be a reason that
people will actually
implement the technology in a way where
we are collaborating with the European
commission and with other industry
partners and research institutions to
develop this technology so
yes it's uh part of the private sector
but it really is a collaboration whether
it's the right approach or not it's a
system which has been put in place which
in our case we believe is effective for
solving this problem you know inevitably
there's always a better way to do
something this is the system that we
have and we'll make the absolute best
that we can of this system yeah keeping
the modern world amazing requires
climate Buckshot lots of solutions all
at once the largest one of which is
decarbonizing our energy Supply and that
means removing our dependence on fossil
fuels in the next few decades
end of but as we've seen there are
emissions from other smaller sectors
that are unavoidable and so need to be
captured mitigated and that's not
accepting defeat that's just being
realistic
but here's the thing we have the answers
we have the tech we just need to do it
and do it faster and accept the fact
that this is a problem that requires
solutions from every angle
one of which is under certain Fringe
cases
the dirty subjects of carbon capture
talking about the climate crisis is like
that old story of Blind Men describing
an elephant one thinks the elephant is
like a broom another like a snake
another like a tree trunk in order to
truly describe the elephant you need
multiple perspectives a video like this
one can only hope to tackle one aspect
and a person like me can only offer one
perspective of the climate crisis
fortunately there are multiple creators
such as are changing climate knowing
better second thoughts not just bikes
and Neo to name just a few that are
talking about it you can watch on
support creators Like Us by signing up
to nebula who have kindly sponsored this
video nebula is the streaming service
used by over half a million people
hosting thoughtful engaging content
across a variety of topics one of which
is the climate crisis by signing up to
nebula you directly support our work and
gain access to bonus content we've
created over the years as well as
enjoying all of our videos without any
advertising in them and with the ability
to download them to watch when offline
later it's just a much better viewing
experience than YouTube but let's say
you're done watching something Indie
made by a YouTuber and you'd rather sit
back and watch something with a bit more
production value well you're in luck
because nebula has partnered up with the
number one source of documentaries on
the web curiosity stream where out of
their thousands of titles across every
subject you can think of you could watch
Greenland is melting or saving Venice
two mini documentaries about different
aspects of the climate crisis the bundle
deal available at curiositystream.com
Simon Clark is phenomenal value not only
is it 26 off the retail price meaning
it's just over a dollar a month for both
services but it gets you the best of
high budget documentaries on curiosity
stream and Indie Productions on nebula
deepening your understanding of the
climate crisis and pretty much any other
subject you'd like to explore that's
curiositystream.com Simon Clark Linked
In the description to feel the elephants
from every angle with thanks to
curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video thank you very
much for watching the video if you did
enjoy it please do pop it a like and
leave a comment with your thoughts it
really does help the algorithmic ranking
of these videos if you'd like to watch
some more stuff from me then here's the
recommended viewing and that just leads
me to say thank you again for watching
I'll see you in the next one